secuelas de un ataque que hace revivir
unas tensiones latentes las alarmas
saltaron en el norte de Israel en la
frontera con el Líbano luego del
lanzamiento de 34 cohetes desde el país
de los cedros 25 de ellos fueron
interceptados por el sistema de defensa
Israel
es algo que ocurre de vez en cuando pero
cuando sucede es un gran impacto aquí
porque hay niños animales y adultos
mayores
el ejército de Israel atribuye el ataque
a milicias palestinas vinculadas al
grupo jamás mientras que desde el Líbano
no ha habido una reclamación de la
autoría por esta ofensiva sin embargo la
agencia nacional libanesa afirmó que
hubo una respuesta con misiles por parte
de Israel algo que este último país
niega
este episodio de violencia llega un día
después de que las fuerzas israelíes
asaltaran los alrededores de la mezquita
de alax en Jerusalén el tercer lugar
Santo más importante para los musulmanes
y en medio del mes sagrado del ramadán
es bola la milicia chiíta libanesa había
condenado dicha incursión y la definió
como una flagrante violación de los
valores religiosos y humanos
mientras que desde la franja de gasas se
lanzaron misiles contra territorio
israelí hasta primeras horas del jueves
Estados Unidos afirmó que Israel tiene
el derecho a defenderse de los
lanzamientos de misiles del Líbano por
su parte Naciones Unidas hizo un llamado
a la calma
gravedad de la situación instamos a la
moderación e instamos a las partes a
evitar una mayor escalada
Israel y el Líbano están aún
técnicamente en guerra siendo el
conflicto de 34 días en 2006 el último
episodio de un enfrentamiento directo